[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
right here
all right and we are live your camino
here at iron lord podcast
multigaming.net
are you then chronicle rising one of the
more highly anticipated games in the
room and who is this fine gentleman we
have here at 505 today my name is zach
uh thank you for coming and checking out
today
want to jump right into it let's jump
right into one of the most highly
anticipated games lord addict on the
gameplay let's check it out
so as we're looking at right now first
of all off the off the rim this game is
beautiful thank you this looks
absolutely stunning the art style looks
great just from a general basic
understanding to an audience that knows
absolutely nothing about evil in
chronicle what can you tell
okay so how far you want to go back you
want to talk about this
i could go back to the second you know
yes exactly because that's the spiritual
i'm from the 108 stars exactly this is
my heart from the the makers i believe
right so break down yes we go we go that
far back so we got yoshitaka mariama
he's creative yeah
exactly and he's here um so iu chronicle
is like the biggest gaming uh kickstart
of 2020. um people are so happy to come
and see it coming back and it did so
well that they're like let's do another
game let's do it we got rising this is
what this one is and this leads into
next year's game which is 100 heroes
100 heroes is more of the traditional
jrpg turn turn-based experience that i
know yeah you're already like please
thank you
exactly this is leading into that as you
can see it's a different gameplay style
it's a side scroller so you have an
action rpg here
but it gives you a chance to meet some
of the characters that you're going to
be seeing in 100 heroes it shows you the
like starting events what kind of leads
and conflicts of that um
it's also there's some crossover content
like items and resources that you can
get nothing too major because the idea
isn't to like punish you for not playing
rising you know it's supposed to be a
good experience so not true you can get
a certain thing name certain items and
it'll carry over 200 heroes so when
you're playing it it's like a content
there's like continuity you've got that
country so you almost move okay is it
fair to say this is almost like a
prelude
in a way right we're calling the
companion game but yeah essentially that
it just
you know it might not be for you because
it's a different gameplay style you know
but we want to give people an entry
point to this world yes a different
style gameplay um
yeah and i actually like actually like
that because it's like again
the john it's been the game has been
away for a while as far as the original
style of game but you got you have a new
generation you want to get them familiar
with the universe and now we have this
2d kind of thing now from an equipment
standpoint i'm seeing now we have two
characters in a party right now was the
garu and the main character yeah cj cj
so
as far as party do we know how maximum
in a party currently or there's three
characters in this one
yeah
you're gonna get your your your ton of
characters gonna be 100 heroes
specifically you know i'm already
thinking
yeah no it's just the three in this one
and you're playing as them all the same
time the way it works is you can switch
between how i'm on the fly um and that's
how you do what are called link attacks
um you're like swapping after attacks uh
and you'll do like powerful combos you
got a question so yeah it's like
they're kind of saying the concept of
like a marvel versus capcom where they
switch into that exactly it's not you
know they're not like jumping in from
off screen or anything like that yeah
yeah it's it's more you know think final
fantasy vii when everybody just walks
into you like original seven they just
walk into you disappear and you're like
i gotta i gotta take that mental leap
and be like oh they're standing behind
me but you know inside me i guess gotcha
so it's
basically the one character
representation but the group is with you
narratively they are there correct
they're all going down into the room
barrows do you want any story set up or
yeah yeah please do please do okay so
what we got here is there in the town of
nudivaya what happened there is
there's been a huge earthquake recently
that basically cracked open these ruins
or a way to get to these ruins
underneath and adventurers from all
around the world know about it and they
know there's treasures there for them to
see
each of the characters are going for
different reasons um we have cj here who
is from a long line of scavengers
basically treasure hunters so this is
her right of passage with her family
she's going in there
um basically proving herself that's her
initial you know motivation at least we
have garu
beastman mercenary you can see his
kangaroo yeah
yeah
he is specifically there to make money
you know but his interests align so they
start teaming up and third you have isha
who's a sorceress she's the daughter of
the mayor of this town
um but he's gone she doesn't know where
she's at so she's stepping into his
shoes
but she's also like
my town's destroyed i gotta make some
money
what if i just start making adventure
passes for everyone around the world i
charge them to explore
so again they all have different
motivations all different motivations
but they're like we got to rebuild the
town too so when you're doing this
there's those light town building
elements where certain items that you
get make it so you can kind of restore
um the town
so as you do that in these towns i want
to expand a little bit on the town
building columnist i'll do my best do
your best yeah you know i like that it's
an added to me dynamic to it like so it
does have effect on what you do in the
town specifically these type of actions
um i wouldn't say it's more choice-based
it's more about like you know you get
enough resources you can add this got it
i don't know if you play darkest
dungeons or i think a little bit more
along those lines
yeah
it's not a dark cloud situation where
you're placing your buildings or
anything like that but yeah totally
understand so we'll check oh my god look
it's great
look at the scroll depth the depth of
field
looks absolutely phenomenal
so is there any like because i noticed
like when i first started there's
equipment
when i click on it is there actual can
you interact with oh you can change it
right now there you go
so i'm kind of curious like is there a
crafting system in this game like where
you can prime certain equipment or i do
not have the answer to that one
unfortunately um because this is you
know it's not the full build of the game
i can get you guys keys for it yeah
that's the other review for next week
yeah this is so cool now we've got a
little battle action going on right now
cool see there you go there's the
swapping nice
now what was the swap addict like what
did you do to do this lock just why it's
simple i like that and then you even got
that cool little transition yeah that
that is so cool now from an arthur this
is all
was this hand drawn so i'm trying to
figure out what this did this looks
amazing kind of a combination so if you
kill his enemy stay still for a second
now if you look she's got that the the
sprite ridging like pixel pixelated um
so you got that going on you have the
actual 3d background so that's how you
get that same depth um i didn't do the
android hendra portraits obviously but
um it's just kind of combination of
everything to make work
but notice there's background uh
destruction in here is there any
particular reason for that kind of
mechanic so you see down there you're
getting sugar lumber and stuff like that
so that's how you get it
you rebuild stuff okay nice so we're
going on getting our adventure on this
is so cool and then i'm also noticing on
some quest items in the upper right
trouble in the quarry round up some
rashes right and these things have
progressed as you do these quests these
are your quest items so to speak exactly
okay cool
check it out
again the legendary
gameplay classic getting familiar with
the universe
and i'll say right now the demo doesn't
have like an ending point so it's kind
of you know when you've got a sense of
what well yeah
and when you want to
you know we definitely yeah this this is
definitely one of those highly answers
for the game how you feeling it man
oh
i wasn't really
feeling like when i first saw it but
like after playing it like it's it's
it's a little more
in depth than i thought it was
thinking the interest
you know last year let's just get this
box over here what's going on with this
box okay
see that's the hope we don't want it to
be too simple like it's not you know a
mobile game that's coming out before
that it's just a full-fledged experience
it's like a 25-30 hour experience it's
the whole thing wow
25 35 that is pretty cool
and again
linking to that main game which will be
the traditional jrpg so paying attention
to what's going to happen narratively is
going to be important because it's not
going to carry over oh yeah exactly and
so the things that they find underneath
it's called in the roon barrows
the ruins underneath that they're all
exploring and basically what eventually
happens there is a big part of what you
know some of the conflicts and
reasonings behind the plot in 100 years
gotcha got you fair enough right now
we're doing our link attacks right now
we're continuing on and and
as far as other like abilities like we
know that each character that there's
obviously some distinction is there any
other things that makes each carrier
character more distinct than the other
let me think about that um
like all day like i know we said three
right but like
well there are certain abilities that
the other ones just cannot do or they
should
it seems like
certain characters are gonna be able to
handle certain ads better than others
yeah it's kind of like the juggling act
of it um
his sword there is a more of a punishing
type of thing you know you can get a lot
of damage in real quick
as you saw we swap for the bigger guy
right now
cj's got those those really fast hits
you don't have to be sure right now but
isha has sorcery so she can cast spells
so you can do this
okay yeah so it's i'm not saying there's
a there's not like different platforming
or anything like that but their combat
is different got it got it
meant to be
have the enemy certain ways right yes
you wouldn't take on
people that have high health reserves
with the smaller ones you would want to
take it off the one that could do them
exactly gotcha now also from a failed
state
again with the swamping if any one of
them goes down
is that a loose condition automatically
or oh we find a boss right now level
five we're gonna find out we're gonna
find out exactly what's gonna happen is
see so there's your hand drone that
you're talking about yes you look at
that tree look at that yeah
absolutely beautiful shooting out some
weird centipede thing we got our man
in there
trying to get in the mix a little boss
action okay little roots action
lucky oh this is evil
you say that when i saw a guy get bodied
[Music]
i like the way i like the animation for
him dude his hops yeah it's really man
yeah cause you're really getting that
hop you're getting that hot that bump
and i noticed there's some form of
platforming too i noticed you probably
come back here or go through the back
there's like a shortcut kind of system
right nice i got a little metrovania
going on yes
checking it out right now diving deeper
into the case
wow again
look at that backdrop seeing the water
seeing everything go down right now
checking things out he's probably saying
he's getting into it we got a little
fishing section boat suction oh fish
okay we got a fishing spot okay
catch fish that you can cook no fishing
rod for now but yeah
i like it
it's interesting i like the
i don't like fighter games but i've
always liked the concept of that marvel
vs capcom kind of thing right and this
is the first game i've ever seen to kind
of capture that same type of game for
you yeah yeah i'm like and like you were
saying it does have that marble feel
when they do leap in four link attacks
when you're swapping them normally
they're just like a quick transition but
i love that when they actually leap off
and like jump in it kind of gives you
that theater to the mind you're talking
about now real quick i don't know if you
can answer this but um with the
fishermen i'm assuming
this is something that you can do to
probably just gain experience or to gain
items in the game or yeah i don't know
if you're sorry right now when there's a
little pop-up window you can get fish to
make cuisine and other artists and stuff
like that
like that yeah exactly yeah so let's
just reverse adventure to the right just
to see a little bit more to the right
after this came at it so let's see a
little bit more
okay yeah just go back up there because
i believe there's a treasure chest and
maybe one of two more things i wanted to
see for the people
with the iu then on
let's jump up
yeah right now i want to see what the
chest and the position
oh so now we got a little bit of puzzle
that's what i said
yeah a little bit of a metronome
clearly needed to figure something out
no doubt
good luck
all right you didn't chronicle
highly anticipated
i know it was first announced i mean
someone wanted the announcements on the
xbox i believe
uh game pass kind of uh it's working as
day one on game pass wow so still day
one on game pass
both games rising and hundreds of games
yes okay
and now how can we talk how far out
release potentially for this role for
ryzen uh one month comes out may 10th
may 10th official release date
man people cannot wait for this
wednesday thank you it's a nice setup a
nice appetizer nice warm up
for the main course but it's history
yeah but it's in its own right it has a
lot going on oh yeah
we can't call an appetizer when it's 25
hours that is true that's it that's a
meal
you'll need a snack for a full day
for 108 stars crowd yeah there you go
it's for them
it might be for them yeah but look you
heard it here first the union chronicles
absolute fantastic game looked up look
out for this one again in game pass and
keep an eye out for it an absolute
pleasure thank you very much
check out this one now
[Music]
you